Plug code is the most powerful AI coding
tool on the planet and using it in
anti-gravity will give you an unfair
advantage. Anthropic just released a
powerful new feature that lets you build
better quality at three times the speed
and have more scalable workflows. And so
in this video, I'm going to show you
exactly how to build Claude's agent
teams feature. I'm going to show you how
to unlock the full capabilities of
Claude with an anti-gravity so you can
build faster and to a better quality
than your competitors. And if you don't
know who I am, my name is Jack Roberts.
I built and sold my last tech startup
with over 60,000 customers. And now I
run a 7figure AI automation business. So
if you haven't already, grab that coffee
and let's dive straight in. So Claude
Code and anti-gravity are unstoppable.
And the words of Johnny Bravo. And we've
just had the brand new Claude Opus 4.6,
which we're also going to include in
this video today. Now, we're going to
cover exactly how to unleash Claude
within anti-gravity. There's been a
brand new update. It is experimental and
I'll touch on what that means in a short
while and it's going to be using several
different agent features that exist
within cloud code that basically lets
you develop and some circumstances three
times faster with better quality code
with more specialized focus and can even
result in more scalable workflows if
though you know exactly how to use it
cuz if you use this the wrong way it can
actually have the adverse effect which
is why I'm going to cover all that in
today's video and I'm going to show you
exactly why it works that way. But
first, Claude I the way I want to think
about Claude in relationship with
anti-gravity if you're not familiar is
Claude is like this super powerful
engine and anti-gravity is the Ferrari.
So the idea here is that one powers the
other. So to say it's Claude versus
anti-gravity would be a bit of a
misnome. It's more anti-gravity is the
vehicle and the engine we're using is
Claude or it could be any other model
like Gemini. Claude is the brain and
anti-gravity is the environment in which
we use Claude. So, all Clude
improvements make anti-gravity more
powerful. They're not in competition in
that sense. So, in this video, I'm going
to show you how to access any Claude
skill within anti-gravity. I'm going to
show you the powerful Oprah skills that
drastically improves Claude code, which
basically takes Claude from a brilliant
but undisiplined junior developer to
someone with coding superpowers. We're
going to use Opus 4.6 anti-gravity. I'm
also going to show you when to use
Claude and importantly Claude's brand
new scum, which is, by the way,
something called Agent Teams. So agent
teams, the best way to think about it is
imagine a classic marketing team, but
instead of people, they are claude
agents and each one of those agents
works on a different task at the same
time. So you'll give Claude an
instruction like, "Hey, I want you to
build me a full stack website." And
Claude will spin up four different
digital employees or four different
agents. This is kind of the the concept
this works. And these agents it spins up
can actually talk to each other
directly. And this is the new feature,
the new wow, this is crazy type of
moment. And they can all share one to-do
list, which is really cool. And each one
of those agents themselves also has a
context window of like up to a million
if you're using the latest model. And
they can even check their own work
before they're finished. Now, the way
this works is you we use anti-gravity.
And within anti-gravity, we decide to
use the Claude model. And effectively,
we create a project and let's say it's a
building a full stack website. Claude
will spin up a project manager agent and
he'll basically create a number of
employees. Could be two, could be 22.
you know there's like a limit to quality
but you get the idea and each one of
these sub agents has a specific task. So
this might be the front- end developer,
this might be the back end, this
person's looking at quality control,
this person's testing, etc., etc., and
they can all talk to each other. So the
idea is like if it's something where
let's say you build like an AI
dashboard, right, and it gets pretty
complex, like there's a lot of
interdependencies, we can actually have
these agents now communicating with one
another within their own context window
and reporting back to this kind of
orchestration agent. They use some kind
of very funky specific terminology. So
sub aents which I'm going to go on to is
very cool can be three times faster
again better quality of code more focus
more scalable workflows but they can be
very token hungry is one of my watch I
want to show cuz I'm going to show you
it's a very powerful tool for specific
circumstance but it can also be token
hungry if you're not using it correctly
but I'll cover that in this video. So
let's unlock claw superpowers with an
anti-gravity. Now to master claude and
unlock its full capabilities
anti-gravity there's actually three
levels of difficulty that we're going to
go through in this video. The first of
which is what I call the clawed code
hacks that sit with an anti-gravity. And
if you've never heard of anti-gravity,
you come over to this website and simply
install it for your computer. And then
you go over to this website here. And
all you're going to do is copy the page
if you've not installed code. Then we
head over to anti-gravity, which is
right over here. And anti-gravity. Then
we're going to upload and basically
create a brand new folder. And if this
sounds like I'm speaking French, go and
watch this video on screen somewhere
that'll teach you the basics of
anti-gravity. and I'll be waiting for
you right here when you come back.
Welcome back. Now, let's dive straight
in. So, what are we going to do? Well,
if you've never installed CL before, you
can be like come to the right and say,
"Hey, install this." And you can do this
with anything really. When you basically
copy a page, throw it in. You're ready
to rock and roll. Now, there are three
ways that you can use Claude code with
an anti-gravity. Way number one is here.
We can select the model and as you can
see, we can do Claude Opus 4.6. Awesome.
The second way, which is cool, and this
is great if anti-gravity ever
misbehaves, so to speak. come down here
on the left hand side. Come over to
extensions and I want you to type in
claude. Think of these extensions kind
of like Chrome extensions in a sense.
You come on, you can select it and then
once you do that, anytime you hit click
on a window, once you've installed it
here, you can see you just double click
and then you'll see the magical Claude
logo. You click on that and then I can
say, "Hey, how's it going?" Right? And
now I'm talking to Claude, which is
great. So this is like chatting with
Claude in the terminal, but it's like a
way better interface basically. And we
can again create as many of these as we
want to. just keep spinning them up to
have many multiple different charts. And
then the other way is at the top. If you
just hover over the top, you can see
you're going to have terminal. So you
just click on terminal, click on new
terminal, and then it appears at the
bottom. And here you can say Claude and
when you say Claude's name, he appears.
We don't need to say it in the mirror
three times either. And then what you
can do with this to make it better is
right click panel position and align
that to the right like that. And then
you have Claude chilling out having a
great time on the left hand side of the
screen. And what is really cool here is
you can duplicate as many as you want to
by hitting this arrow like this. You
see, just keep on doing that. Basically,
adding an item and you've got all of
these different basically claw terminal
browsers running in anti-gravity.
Another little hack for you, by the way,
is that you can actually use certain
models within anti-gravity for free by
using something called Open Code. I'll
put a link for it somewhere on screen so
you can check that out. But effectively,
all you would do is literally come over
to the terminal here and say install
Open Code like so. This will then go
ahead and grab it, install it, and then
when you run that code, you can access
over 100 Frontier models. You can even
use your chat GBT plus subscription if
you ever find out that you're running
out of tokens within anti-gravity. The
other thing to call out as I mentioned
is that the token usage for Claude Opus
4.6 with an anti-gravity is free.
However, it is more limited than the
Gemini 3 Pro high because that's a
native model to Google. So, you kind of
get more leeway that way. One little
hack that some people do, by the way, is
they will actually come over and switch
their account so they get like more
free. I personally am more on the
advanced plan. I find that it's really
worth it because I get lots of usage and
it kind of kicks bum. Instead of just
googling it, you can also just grab the
open code install which you can do
directly from this page. Literally
coming over, copying this, heading back
over to anti-gravity, you can just
literally enter it in right there. I
mean, it's already found it, but if you
wanted to be really specific, you could
physically do that. Sweet. And now
that's done. Let's open up the terminal
window just to check this. So, new
terminal. And all we say is quite simply
open code. And then you should see the
open code appear for us instantaneously
once that loads up. And it's over there.
And then if you've done that, it'll pop
up. You can then do things like check
the models, make various different
decisions. You kind of pretty much name
it. But I'll link a full video so you
can check that one out in a bit more
detail. But this is one thing. But the
question is, how do we really leverage
the full powers of Claude with an
anti-gravity? Cuz most people don't even
really scratch the surface. And the
first way that we do that is using
something called skills. Now, Claude
skills can effectively be anti-gravity
skills. They're basically packets of
information, instructions that we've
worked out and specified that give
guardrails and enhancements. and think
of them as like a mech suit for your
model. So, for example, so I've got
these Oraclaw superpowers which are
insane. I've got this full guide here on
Claude agent teams. I'm going to put all
these resources down below so you can
just copy and paste and get rocking and
rolling. But what we're going to look at
here is a specific library that is
really profoundly powerful. And this one
here is the superpowers plugin by almost
50,000 stars which is code for really
freaking cool. What this will enable us
to do very simply and the key difference
I want you to understand with skills to
leverage the best out of claude and
anti-gravity is that without superpowers
without skills your coding agents
basically like a junior dev really smart
not very well directed the idea is that
when we give them these codified skills
through things like brainstorming and
thinking it's efficiency goes through
the roof so the benefit stops claude
from wing it stops bugs from compounding
and it stops claude from lying to you
and hallucinating based on his specific
so just think about someone's built
excellence they've codified it and then
we get Claude to use that. So there's
loads of really incredible use cases.
You can see review skills, meta skills,
lots of great stuff. So any skills that
you want to learn. Another great
example, by the way, is this one here,
which is awesome. Cloud skills. Again,
I'll put the links below for you. That
basically gives it the ability to
programmatically edit things like word
documents, Microsoft, Excel sheets, you
name it, it can physically do it. So
when you find a skill package that you
like, all you're going to do is come
down here, click on the code, click on
copy. Then we're going to head over to
anti-gravity and say, "Hey, install
these skills here for me." Right? And
then all you're going to do is literally
paste in a link. That'd be pretty handy,
right? We can do that. And they'll add
it for you directly into your
environment. And now that's complete.
You can see on the left hand side we've
got all the skills. You can add macro
skills to set across everything as well,
of course. So I'm going to get a prompt
here, which is if I building a test
product, how would you approach this?
Use skills if you have relevant ones.
Now, typically speaking, you should
never really need to do this. So if I
click into brainstorming for example,
check out the brainstorming skill. You
can see it's got a description. Use this
before any creative work. So normally
speaking, the context within this
claopus 4.6 knows that I'm doing
something creative. Therefore, I must
use the brainstorm skill and it will do
that most of the time, but these models
are probabilistic and there's very rare
occasions where sometimes they don't. So
if you wanted to be a bazillion% sure,
you can just prompt it to use the skill.
But most of the time, you shouldn't
really have to do that. It depends how
comfortable you are with the situation.
But normally these will actually pull
them for you dynamically without
thinking about them. And we can see now
it's analyzed various different skills
to see exactly how it should behave when
thinking about this. And then we have
this brainstorming prompt which is
understand the product context one
question at a time proposed two to three
approaches. It's built a full phase plan
for us now using these codified skills
which is fantastic. So it's literally
thought about this in detail
programmatically and I've given us steps
to do that. And you can give them steps
that include code like the ones that
will edit documents in HTML. Think of
them as like incredible upgrades to
leverage with claude code with an
anti-gravity. So now you've learned some
of the hacks of using claw code with an
anti-gravity. The next step is to use a
feature that will literally let you code
and do things three times faster than
actually using it traditional way. And
the crazy part is that most people don't
even know that this thing exists. So
we're going to come to our workflow and
let's just refresh and get rid of
everything. Now to do this, what we're
going to use up here is going to be the
terminal. So click on terminal, click on
new terminal, and we want to activate
Claude. If your terminal isn't on the
right and you'd like it there, remember
you can always right click and decide
the panel position, top, right, bottom,
it doesn't really matter. It's a
preference. Personally speaking, I like
to go from left to right, which is why I
have it there. Now, here's what you're
going to do to demonstrate the power of
this. Right click over here, or you can
just add a folder up here, and we'll
call this one research. Okay, so for
example, let's give it the below prompt,
which is three sub agents running in
parallel. One production, five
production use cases for Python, five
for Rust, five for Go. Save each as its
own output markdown file in the research
folder. Bam. I'm going to send this one
off. So what is happening here, really
important to understand, is that Claude
has its own context window. This one, I
believe, a million tokens. When it
spawns these sub agents, they exist
temporarily during this conversation.
Each of these sub agents has its own
context window, right? And what we're
saying here is we have what we call
these parallel agents. In other words,
they can work on the thing at the same
time as the other one. So, one could be
doing API calls while the other one can
crack on with something else. It's like
us three being in a house trying to sell
it, right? And I've got to paint and
maybe you got to clean the kitchen and
someone else has got to install the
radiators, but we're all saying, "Well,
we're going to wait till Jack's finished
before I can start." Well, if we all
separated and did three different things
simultaneously, we'd get the job done so
much quicker and we'd sell it, right?
And that's kind of like the idea with
this. And as you can see right now once
I come back over here, it's launching
these different sub aents. That's a
different part of anti-gravity kicking
off if you're wondering. But look at
this, right? We've got Python again.
Five tools used, five tools used, five
tools used. All this research is
happening independently. Now, these
agents aren't talking to each other, but
what they are doing is doing deep
research. And if this was being used by
Claude itself, this would take
significantly longer to do. And just
like that, we've got all three saved in
a research folder. And look at how
comprehensive. I mean, this is literally
how many lines of code? Like over 745.
This feature is crazy. And it's so much
faster than having Claude do it itself.
Spinning up these sub agents and having
them work in parallel. Now, sub agents
are phenomenal. But the biggest
drawback, so to speak, is the fact that
they cannot communicate with each other.
Agent A has no idea or context what
agent B is doing or vice versa. But what
if there was a way to actually have
these agents communicate with each
other? And this brings us to Claude's
latest experimental feature which is
called Claude agent team. So what are
agent teams? Well, in simple language,
they are Claude Code's multi- aent
orchestration system. And that sounds
pretty complex. The TLDDR is allow
multiple AI agents to work together in
parallel, communicate directly, and then
coordinate what we call complex tasks.
So basically instead of one developer
working alone, you now have a team of
specialists working simultaneously with
their own focus. Keep being the fact
that they can communicate with each
other. So how do you install it? Well,
basically you just open this up here and
what you can do literally is on this
page just copy the page then head over
to anti-gravity and then with
anti-gravity just say hey install this
and then you can paste the entire page
and it will literally install that for
you with an anti-gravity. And whilst
that's doing that, I want to kind of
draw a bit of a differentiate between
agent teams and sub agents that we just
used. Again, sub agents super cool,
super powerful. The biggest difference
is earning context window fully
independent. Whereas with sub agents, it
reports back to the main agent, right?
But what's really interesting here is
that the token cost for agent teams is a
lot higher. And if you think about that,
it's because they have to communicate
with one another. There's an additional
dimension of communication, which is why
this can burn tokens. It's a very
specific tool with a lot of potential,
but just be aware that it can actually
be quite token intensive, but there are
some strategies that you can use and
I've detailed a lot of them here. So,
for example, what we can do is have the
most powerful model as the brain and
then we can actually come down here and
then deploy different models for lesser
tasks that don't require that. For
example, we can deploy Sonet 4.5 or
Haiku. And here's a cost tokens just to
give you an overview. So, you can
leverage this feature without
necessarily like rinsing your API
credits. Super duper interesting. And
you can see some of the other things
there. This is best for focused tasks
where the result only matters. Whereas
agent teams are good for complex work
requiring discussion and collaboration.
And I'm going to go into a bit more
detail about the stuff that I found. I'm
always going to share with you the stuff
that works. If it's new, we're going to
test it. And if it's great, I'll let you
know. And if it isn't, I'll also let you
know. So, we're very very independent on
how we do things to think about this.
And there are some use case I want to
really throw by you here. So, once we
come back over to anti-gravity, we're
going to allow it in this conversation
to download it. So according to this, it
is fully running and rocking and
rolling. So let's come over and test
this for example in the terminal and
click on new terminal and we're going to
remove this over here to test it. So
we're going to come down here and
activate claude. One little small
feature by the way that I want you to
think about when you're building agents
is the actual feature in anti-gravity.
So we've just shown you how you can spin
up these sub aents. But within
anti-gravity, right, you have this agent
manager feature right here. And this is
really cool because we could in theory
have these mini agents by saying, "Hey,
for example, I could click on use
playground," which is like a blank
canvas. And I could be like, "Hey, do
X." Then I could spin up another one and
be like, "Hey, do Y." Right? And I could
spin up as many as I want to. The
advantage of the sub agent is the fact
that it's all managed by Claude. But one
interesting differentiator here, by the
way, I just want to throw you away, is
the fact that if you look at any of
these things, like let's say you've got
an invoice generator like I do. What I
can do with mine now is I can go into
this folder at any time I want by
literally clicking into it for instance
and then saying hey write me an invoice
for XYZ and it already has all that
project context which is a complete game
changer with anti-gravity and we're
still using the best code model to do
that. So to test this, we're just going
to ask it, do you have the ability to
create agent teams and what commands do
you have? And we know this because I've
actually detailed everything it can do
in this document for you. Task create,
task list, task get, task update. So
again, all this is going to be available
for you down below in the description
completely for free. So you can have a
rock on a good time. And does it look
normal to you? We got brainstorm,
dispatch, and parallel agents, executing
plans. And as you can see, it says yes,
I have access to these tools, team
coordination tools, task correct, task
get. Awesome. So now we're going to
ahead and give it a prompt. And I want
to drill down to something important
here. So, this is the prompt that we're
going to give it to build a to-do app.
Okay, an agent team prompt. We're going
to have one guy who does the copy, one
guy that does the designer UI, and one
person does the features. If you start
to bloat the team, just like in
business, right? Like if you and I were
doing a business together, and we had a
QA guy and a safety guy, the every
dimension you add and require
intercommunication, it gets bureaucracy.
So, agents apparently are not immune to
bureaucracy. And one of the things I
found is that, you know, every team
member must earn their spot on your
agent team. Otherwise, not only will
they be more expensive, it will be a lot
slower and not efficient. So, think
about how they could be specific. Now,
the only time you're going to use agent
teams is if they need to talk to each
other and intercommunicate. So, these
are really cool ones. One guy just
focused on the copy, one's on design and
UI, and one's on the features. So, what
we're going to do is literally come down
here. We're going to copy all of this,
and we're going to compare this with
building one just directly by itself
using Claude. So, so we're going to come
down, come down here, paste it, and see
exactly what they build for us.
Beautiful. So, now we have two apps. We
have app A and then we have app B. I'll
let you make a decision on which one
that you prefer. But if we check out
this one as for instance, I can say,
"Hey, I need to buy apples." I add that
in. It's there. I can take it. Pretty
sweet. It's crossed off the list. Now
it's the done section. If I untick it,
it's now in the active. Pretty cool. We
can go ahead and sign out as well and
give us cool login page. Overall, pretty
decent. Then we got the second one here,
which is, "Hey, demo." I can add a task
up here. Already I've got more things I
can do here, like hey, hey, what's up?
Description priority high. And then we
can set the due date. Again, it's it's
lacking a little bit of polish to be
fair. It's not quite as visually
brilliant, but it does hit more
specifics. Add the task. And then we can
see it's all down here. We can select
this. We can delete it. Yes, delete it.
So, you can see now the interesting
levels of detail we're getting in this
one. Got active and got complete. I
wouldn't love these design. These are
one shot. Bear in mind, all I said is
build it, right? So, it's not exactly
like multilayer, but these are the two.
And interestingly, this is the one done
by agent teams. And this one here was
done completely by claude by itself. Now
this leads to a very interesting
conclusion with this. Now this project
had one UI layer, one data layer and one
flow. So agent teams for a project like
this is overkill. We also have when
you're using very simple projects with
agent teams a communication tax because
just like a normal business all of the
individual agents or employees have to
communicate with one another. So not
only might it not be as good quality as
a oneshot some say slightly better, some
say it's slightly lower ballpark. The
point is it will get there a lot slower
because of the communication overkill.
So the TLDDR is if you can explain the
whole task in a couple of sentences, use
an individual AI to build them. But if
it's something that requires a
multiplicity to use a very fancy word,
lots of lots of independent
interrelating things where you need the
agents to carefully coordinate with each
other, you may opt towards the agent
teams model instead. For example, if I'm
building a simple to-do list, I might
just use AI. But if I'm building a full
multi-stack dashboard with
authorizations, payments, dashboards,
the whole works, there might be
something more in the agent teams
version. We can also, as I showed you,
actually cut our cost down by having the
most powerful model up front and then
lesser expensive models underneath that
to execute on it. Now, understanding how
to leverage CL code and anti-gravity is
one thing, but if you don't know how to
connect anti-gravity to one of the most
powerful tools on the planet, you're
almost certainly leaving value on the
table. And we can learn how to do that
by watching this video right